[Music]
it's alex gordon day at kauffman stadium
please welcome back to kauffman stadium
left fielder number four
alex gordon last year became only the
third player in major league history to
win a gold glove in his final season
alex won a platinum glove in 2014
and last year became the only player in
major league history to win a platinum
glove
in his final season and that number
forward that image is what hangs over
his old locker he has been given that
as well
one of five
players who spent their entire career
with this organization on the hill for
the royals carlos hernandez this is a
guy who can reach 100 miles an hour if
he can locate it properly he can be
tough
how about that
going right with the change up and
getting the strike out of scope who has
been their hottest hitter of late
casey mais on the mound making his 19th
start he's faced the royals four times
already in his short career
he got him looking mize wins that
one-on-one battle two away
now the 2-2
that's lace to left and badoo makes a
fine running grab
to retire the royals in order
the 1-0 to right field for a base hit
one ball no strikes to harold castro
on the ground to first santana with a
nice play to get a runner at second they
can't double up castro and a run will
come home miguel cabrera scores the
tigers like last night take the early
lead in kansas city one nothing
hernandez at the belt
brings it home and a swing and a miss
got him with a breaking ball to end the
inning more favorable the pitch count
better pitch you're gonna get
just over his head here comes the third
baseman candelaria bobbles the ball
can't make the play and o'hare is going
to be safe throwing high fastballs to a
good high ball hitter you can get in
some trouble swinging a miss had a
slider down and away he just wiped out
dozier with a terrific slider
back to back walks to open the third
inning
not a good sign for carlos hernandez
the bases are loaded because of walks
grossman is aboard
and the bases are loaded for miguel
cabrera three walks in the inning to
load the bases right here and perfect
spot for miguel cabrero drives one to
right field
o'hearn makes a nice grab
it's deep enough to score derek hill
miguel cabrera has himself a sacrifice
fly and it's two nothing tigers two and
two to jammer candelario
it's a fly ball to deep center field
taylor going back that ball is gone in
the batter's eye it's a three-run blast
and the tigers have opened it up here in
the third jamer right there put a nice
swing on a guy that throws the ball real
hard
wave and a miss casey mize has his third
strikeout of the night and it's a big
one to get the
more dangerous lead off men in all of
baseball with merrifield
the 2-2
swung on him missed no problem for casey
my second time that he does santana and
he leaves a man in scoring position 11
pitches for mize in the third perez
lined out to aqil badu his first time up
in left field hit it well but badou had
a nice jump on it this one is sprayed to
right robbie grossman tracking it and he
slides
and puts it away that was a very very
good catch right there not easy to do
the two two
swung on and missed casey mize
overpowered in there that is strikeout
number five on the night for mize and
there's two up and two down in the
kansas city board
the 1-1 there it is he goes to right
field
just like clockwork
just a great piece of hitting and the
hitting streak continues for jonathan
scope make it 14 straight and the tigers
have runners at the corners with nobody
out
singled and scored in the second and a
sacrifice fly in the third
fly ball right field
o'hearn feeling for the fence he's got
it a couple of feet deep on the warning
track
another sacrifice fly for miguel cabrera
he brings home a kill badou
and the tigers are up a half a dozen
to put the bat on the ball find some
holes and get on the board here
100 dozier will lead things off and he
grounds one up the middle tough play for
castro and he can't come up with it that
should be a base hit for dozier because
that was a very difficult play for
harold castro it is a base hit
ground ball base hit through the whole
left side
so now to be the number nine hitter
vicky lopez digs in
in the alley right center grossman can't
reach it
here comes dozier he will score and the
royals are on the board
trailing six to one
good at-bat by lopez now salvador perez
who has been clutch for the royals the
entire year
oh
and deep and that ball is long gone
salvador perez has the royals right back
in it salvi's 22nd homer and it was a
beauty
three for three is nikki lopez
and ties at career high with his seventh
three-hit game
[Applause]
two right field
lopez will stop at second base
first and second only one out with
santana coming up
six four tigers in the bottom of the
seventh there are two on and one out for
carlos santana
santana swings and it's a line drive
deep into right field and it is gone
and the royals have come all the way
back to take the lead
short quick compact back underside fans
calling for a curtain call
that was
timely
how about a deuter
perez continues the inning with his
second hit of the night
ball four
so funkhouser is leaking oil and he was
really terrific the last 10 games we
told you only one run allowed in his
previous 16 and a third innings ian
kroll comes out of the bullpen and
immediately mike matheny changes up by
bringing on hanzo alberto
it well centerfield
derek hill
can't get there perez scores ben tendy
scores alberto with a triple the royals
lead by three
heck white settle for a double when you
could hit a triple i mean he unloaded on
this fastball
fly ball deep right field
dyson's got it oh he dropped it
haas all the way into second base
the leadoff man is aboard for the tigers
here in the ninth
tigers need one more base runner to
bring the potential tying run to the
plate but do as the lineup turns over
sends one to deep right field that goes
dyson he'll watch it fly
a two-run blast for aquila badou and the
tigers aren't done yet
well that was a no doubter
here it is
didn't get the chance
walks cabrera
two men on two men out in the ninth mike
matheny scene it up and wade davis comes
out of the bullpen wade last pitched on
sunday versus baltimore recorded a one
two three ninth
check swing did he go
yes he did
and wade davis gets the save and the
royals survive
way to pick up
your longtime friend
greg holland with a nice strikeout to
help him out there finishing it up in
the royals
coming back the largest deficit comeback
win since june of 2017. amazing